I have a suggestion for Beto O'rourke today.
Uh, Beto should leave the presidential campaign.
Go back to Texas and challenge the other Texas
Senator Republican John Cornyn for his seat
in 2020.
I'm going to make the case for you here if
you disagree with me.
Okay?
Don't tell me that I'm an anti Beto shill
in the primary.
Don't t listen, skip it all.
Tell me which of my facts are wrong or which
don't.
Point to this being a good idea.
I'm going to build the case up for you here.
In 2016, Donald Trump won Texas over Hillary
Clinton by about 52 to 43.
It was a nine point margin by which Donald
Trump defeated Hillary Clinton in Texas.
In 2016, uh, in 2012, Mitt Romney defeated
Barack Obama in Texas by a margin of 16, meaning
Trump's margin in Texas in the last presidential
election was not nearly as big as Mitt Romney's
in 2012 and in 2008, even though, as I'm sure
you know, Barack Obama defeated John Mccain
in the presidential election, Mccain also
beat Obama by a much larger margin than, uh,
Trump's, uh, margin of victory over Hillary.
It was a 12 point margin of victory for Mccain
over Obama in Texas in 2012.
So for starters, number one, in 2016, Texas
was closer in the presidential election than
it had been in a long time.
In 2018, Beto O'rourke ran against Texas senator
Ted Cruz.
Now, Ted Cruz ended up winning that, uh, reelection
campaign.
It was very close, 50 point 89% to 48 point
33%.
The margin of victory for Ted Cruz over Beto
O'rourke as the incumbent Republican senator
in Texas was only about two and a half percentage
points.
This is a very slim margin for an incumbent
Republican senator in Texas.
Beto O'rourke then decided to take the name
recognition that he built to some degree,
uh, during his 2018 senate run against Ted
Cruz and run for president.
And unfortunately, Beto O'rourke is not doing
well in his presidential campaign.
So we're putting up on the screen the polling,
uh, for a variety of Democratic candidates.
Baytos polling is the pink line, which we
have signaled for you in the graphic.
And you'll notice that Bedo was polling as
high as nearly 10% some months ago, and it's
just been a steady and consistent decline
down to now averaging only about three and
a half percent in national polls is Beto O'rourke.
In a recent Iowa poll, which is the first
2020 caucus state betos polling only 2%.
Okay.
So Beto has fallen from some level of grace
we could say.
And the reality is, Beto is not going to be
so impressive once the upcoming democratic
debates start, that he's going to regain anything
close to a real shot at being the Democratic
nominee.
However, there's no denying that Beto O'rourke
is more well known today than he ever has
been.
So what better or work should do is leave
the presidential, uh, race gracefully.
I mean, participate in the first or second
debate next month, uh, since he's in them,
he's qualified.
Continue to Nate, raise his name recognition
a little bit, but then go back to Texas and
run against the other Texas senator Republican
John Cornyn, because as I told you in another
story today, Donald Trump's favor ability
in Texas right now is only plus three, which
is very low for Republican candidate in the
state of Texas.
The mood in general is good for another run
by Beto O'rourke in Texas.
And importantly, Cornyn's even less popular
than Ted Cruz in Texas.
There is a February, 2019 Paul, which is four
months old, but it's still relatively illuminating.
Uh, and um, uh, the favoribility rating for
John Cornyn is lower in Texas now.
Then Ted Cruz's was when, uh, better org ran
against him in 2018.
So this is a very strong way to number one
may be Turner red seat blue, but also to cause
the Republican party to have to invest a bunch
of money in defending John Corn and seat Beto
has until I believe it's early December to
file for the Senate election in Texas.
Beto is not going to have any serious impact
on this presidential race.
Beto could immediately have an impact in Texas.
He could force the Texas Republican Party
and even the National Republican National
Committee to at minimum spend a ton of money
defending John Corn and seat.
Maybe John Cornyn can even be defeated in
Texas.
And when we look at the 2020 math for the
Senate and we realize the math just doesn't
look good for Democrats because of which a
third of the Senate seats are up for reelection,
we're assuming that John Cornyn definitely
gets reelected better would have a shot.
People don't love John Cornyn.
The mood in Texas is almost as liberal as
it has ever been, if not as liberal as it
has ever been.
Texas isn't thrilled with Trump.
Cornyn has been mostly a Trump guide.
This is a real opportunity.
Beto should get out gracefully.
I get it.
Participate in a debate or two so you can
raise more money.
Keep your name in the news to some degree,
but then use the name recognition and go run
against the Republican senator in Texas where
he has a much better shot than he has of becoming
the Democratic presidential nominee.
What do you think?
Okay.
If you disagree with any of the facts that
I'm using to come to this conclusion, tell
me where I'm wrong on the facts.
If you agree with the facts, but disagree
with my conclusion.
I also want to hear from you.
Uh, if you're just going to send out homonyms
skip it.
Just not worth it.
We don't have time for it.
We've got, yeah,
real business to deal with here.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Make sure you're following me@david.tax as
well